some elder members of the First United
Methodist Church in Teleco Plains
Tennessee got together they were going
to celebrate Thanksgiving they stayed
late to talk about the problem of
shootings in churches and during the
conversation about shootings and
churches a man accidentally shot himself
as well as his wife what was the over 80
year old man doing while he was showing
off his gun what else he has a 380
caliber Ruger handgun which he takes
everywhere with him almost like a pet
dog
he removed the magazine cleared the
chamber and showed the gun off then he
put the magazine back in and apparently
accidentally loaded a round into the
chamber as he put the gun back into the
holster someone else reportedly walked
up and said can I see that he pulled it
back out and said with this loaded
indicator I can tell that it's not
loaded he pulled the trigger evidently
forgetting or not realizing that he had
chambered the weapon and it ended up
going through because of how it was
placed on a table it ended up going
through the bullet did his hand and his
wife's abdomen the injuries didn't
appear to be life-threatening and
charges will obviously not be filed
because it's just a good Christian white
dude in a church I haven't mentioned
this for a while but the concept of an
accidental shooting from a legal
perspective is really dubious right if
you didn't mean to fire the weapon then
it's a negligent discharge which needs
to be punished I don't know if it should
be a fine losing your gun or what but it
is a public negligent discharge of a
firearm you didn't intend to fire it and
it was fired by you at minimum there
should be some kind of fine here treat
all guns as if they are loaded at all
times this guy didn't do it right he
became confident that it wasn't loaded
and decided to pull the trigger never
point the gun at something you don't
want to shoot he pointed the gun at both
his own hand and his wife's abdomen if
he had been treating the weapon is
loaded he never would have pulled the
trigger if he's never pointing the gun
at something he didn't intend to shoot
then his wife wouldn't have been in the
way when he decided to pull the trigger
how is this not the very definition of a
negligent discharge it's an old guy in a
church though so I
it's no problem have a good day sir and
also he said that the loaded indicator
told him that it wasn't loaded
either he misread the loaded indicator
which again is evidenced that maybe this
guy is not fit to own firearms or the
loaded indicator wasn't working in which
case shouldn't a gun that was used to
shoot two people because of a faulty
loaded indicator shouldn't that gun be
confiscated
how on earth is the right path forward
here for the police to do absolutely
nothing just a bizarre story